from the University of Vienna who's
going to tell us about many-body physics
and complexity theory good morning I'm
giving two talks in this bootcamp and I
decided to divide them in all two ways
first today I'm gonna try to possibly
find a common language between many-body
physics and complexity theory and
actually show like what are the problem
that we're interested in here and why
they are hard and why new complexity
guys should be interested in them on
this side then on the talk on Saturday
I'll probably change a little from what
was written in the list I'm gonna tell
you how we're doing
so after zest talked on on course on
tensor networks and matrix product
states I'm gonna tell you how we're
using them about the success stories in
1d and also about the tough problems in
1d and then possibly we'll go to the
higher dimension and talk a little bit
about peps and continue from there again
the second talk will be more on also
simulations how we're using the
Hamiltonians but first we'll go to what
are the questions that we are asking in
many body physics many body physics or
for example strongly correlated
electrons is a vast subject that has
produced many many results that are have
our fantastic theoretically and have
great applications like for example just
to give you a couple of things for which
Nobel prizes are awarded like
high-temperature superconductors for
which we're trying to find a theory of
magnetism that needs for a strongly
correlated electrons or the fractional
quantum Hall effect or which we're
hoping that's gonna or exhibit things
like topological codes and refining
system where we could actually implement
this but we're apart from that but we're
trying to understand these systems the
goal of our many-body physics is on one
hand investigate systems that we find in
nature and try to explain their behavior
in terms of simple models on the other
hand we can also try as theorists but
also in practice to try to use these
things that we've got or the models to
construct something to predict and this
is going to be probably more on the
second talk all of this is talking about
hamiltonians Hamiltonians are
ways of describing how particles
interact we have these microscopic small
rules about how each electron interacts
with another electron and how it hops
around the lattice and we're trying to
figure out what the bulk properties are
going to be is this thing that we've got
is it going to be a magnet is it a thing
that doesn't want to cool down or it's a
thing that cools down easily is it a a
molecule that will fold out in this way
or fold out in that way and then we'll
have these extra properties for example
just things like is this material gonna
be dense or not is what is his capacity
can we can be heated up easily or not is
it magnetism magnetized are things that
are far away correlated and could we
possibly use these correlations for
something and just even what's the
spectrum so when the electrons in the
system how what levels can they be in
can they run around and can they conduct
or will will be an insulator model of
interactions first could be classical
we're going to be talking about lot
about classical models and then about
quantum models today so first we have an
energy a cost function for strings so
imagine that we have spins that could be
pointing up and down only just classical
zeros and ones or we can have quantum
Hamiltonians where we are really looking
at the quantum operators left act on
vectors in huge hilbert spaces and we're
trying to find eigen vectors and try to
do something with them there are
interactions because if there if there
are no interactions then we would just
have like one body Hamiltonians we would
solve it for one particle and then
possibly their electrons then we just
use several of these solutions for one
particle and and to symmetrize and
understand everything but once things
get interacting becomes difficult and
especially in strongly interacting
systems we are going to be talking about
Hamiltonians that are local so when you
tell hotel OCONUS matter physicist a
local hamiltonian it really doesn't mean
the same local as for for the computer
scientist so local means the first few
body so it's only like you can divide
the interactions so that I can take in
the term of us interacting you guys
interacting and not just like terms
where everybody affects everybody at the
same time so non-trivial terms only
involving a few particles at a time and
second a local Hamiltonian would be one
that has a short range so that means
that for example in a chain with a
nearest neighbor interaction I only am
affected by my neighbors directly as
terms in the Hamiltonian of course there
will be correlations later that go
further on or next nearest neighbor
chain so local means short-range few
body maybe we should start using a
different different word for when we
were talking about local Hamiltonians
because we just often talk about the
general graphs where things are not
really on a lattice or not which could
be just like anything connected with
anything that's like really far away and
there's no real simple world the
geometry there so maybe you should keep
saying geometrically local yes no no no
no I don't I don't think so yes that's
we that's something that we would
ultimately want this also really like
something that you can put in space so
that there will be like really a lattice
particle size dimensions we might not
like fit like a too many particles in a
we might we might fit something that
looks like a particular geometry and
then we won't cannot really grow the
system anymore so like the things like
the corals with the hyperbola geometry
or something
it's but it's a good it's a good
question like how can we really like
make can we build a system where like I
I actually am interacting with with
those guys and with those guys and not
with these guys that are close I have to
put it in space somehow and that is that
is definitely definitely difficult at
the moment we think we do and there was
a question
so short-range meaning that if I have if
I actually have a lettuce that I'm
interacting only within the neighbor so
this is probably like the strongest
interaction and then I'm repulsed by the
second row a little bit less and then
less and less so I can even forget about
what's most fun so that's actually in
space yes so I'm thinking of a lettuce
and I'm thinking of short range and it's
a it's an approximation that will be
like if generally very the interactions
fall off
so local Fargo or whatever I used to
hear would be just like okay few
particles at a time locally to drop what
cleaner you know like is the number of
neighbors or another question so it's
also sufficient to talk is it also
sufficient to talk about systems that
are dual to systems in a few bodies
ensuring interaction is it enough to
talk about systems that are dual to
these I I don't know okay let's go on
naturally for any nature there's some
long term long-range interactions I mean
you might not be able to control a
little bit diseases yeah you can like
even if you arrange things then you can
make a lot have it an effective
long-range interaction that doesn't fall
off as strongly as you would think just
even that allows us to it like send
waves radio waves or something that like
not really falling off like 1 over R
square R squared but like 1 over R or
using some kind of interference effects
or something so I'm thinking maybe of if
effective Hamiltonian not really the
ones that we find so we might be able to
construct something like that but I'm
out on a limb so I I don't know another
question so when we go to be talking
about long range interactions and many
interactions so like a particle
interacting with many things at a time
you'll see that in our own stock let's
see what happens then so let's talk
about a particular lattice so for
example we have the easy model on a on a
chain it's anti ferromagnetic we're
talking about strings and the cost
function is saying that like okay when
the two two things are not pointing in
the same direction does the change is
happy because you get a minus sign here
the energy goes down and then also if
they're pointing in a particular
direction then there have been some
there's some kind of frustration and
they support it investigating another
hand this this problem is easy we can
look at it in a
3d when there's just more neighbors and
this somehow this problem seems to be
hard and we really haven't solved this
problem we're going to be talking about
what does it mean to solve a problem a
little bit later then let this
dimensionality or like though this this
is talking about like how what the space
is like is so we can view it as like I'm
in a particle and then I'm interacting
or I can go to the next ones and to the
next ones and see how far I can get in n
steps so you know in a 3d space I give
just basically n to the third button
like just for hyperbolic space or
something I can get to like many and
there will be infinite dimension a spin
so this is a particular lattice a
particular model so you see that for
example the interactions are the same at
every site or like the the particles are
affecting each other the same way
everywhere so this is an instance for a
computer scientist but this is very
important for the condensed matter
physicist because a party oh this might
be just a model of em of a magnet we
really do we later would want to see
like okay what happens when we have
slight disorder so we there are like
some small changes in the couplings or
like when when we don't really have a
lattice but the lattices change a little
bit or we have some impurities or
something so even particular models are
hard are difficult to solve so once you
change the couplings inside you get a
spin glass and that that problem just
gets an order of magnitude more
difficult unless what we sometimes do we
just try to look at like not really the
worst case but the average case so what
happens if these things like for example
are chosen at random and that's another
way of looking at things another model
that you might might see in Connors
matter is for example the Heisenberg
model which is a slight generalization
of this where this was the the easy
water was something that he proposed for
magnetism and he solved it in 1d and he
didn't find something very interesting
so he just let it be and then for for
years I think was from 24 to 49 or so he
didn't even do physics afterwards and
then he came to the US and then he
realized that he's famous because people
have found interesting things in his
model not in 1d but in 2d and 3d which
he conjectured that won't be interesting
so and that's also by Heisenberg has
proposed this model to be like more
complicated be richer and it actually is
much richer and then though instead of
just having zero one strings you think
of those as vectors so for example if
it's ten you can think of them as 3d
vectors but they could be in more higher
dimensional spaces and if this is on a
chain and then for example instead of
just having the same coupling for the
same direction but you're indifferent
once and you have an extra field that
that model has been studied a lot and
then for particular things that where
this is the spin that's half integer or
an integer as we know the long-standing
problem the hunting conjecture that
stopped me about why where for some for
the half integer and for the interest
rates one of them is gapped and one of
these or this type of system should be
gapless and we haven't proved that yet
only for special cases
so the conjecture is that like this
model when you make a really long chain
and when the spin that's I let's see I
hope I don't say it wrong when when we
about half integer spin there shouldn't
be a gap and when there's an integer
spin there should be again I think that
one of them is done the hospital spin I
think is done yeah then oh so this is
the XYZ model or Heisenberg where these
three are different you can see the X X
X Y mono where these two couplings are
the same this one is different you can
look at what happens when you change the
ratio so beast-like which one is
stronger which one is weaker or just an
X X model when you have these two terms
and so on so this was for a particular
lattice so say 3d or one need or we can
be talking about these general graphs
yes
so I think for Oh
for example the Heisenberg spin chain or
with the same things everywhere it's
solved by betting on that we're gonna be
talking about that a little bit yeah in
one go yes so when we talk about general
graphs for example another model that's
very important is the boast Hubbard
model is when well is instead of just
having spins we're gonna be talking
about particles particles that three
fermions or bosons or fermions which
though you cannot have two of them at
the cell of the same type at the same
spot that are hopping so this is an
annihilation operator a creation
operator that takes a particle makes it
disappear at one spot and makes it
appear at a neighboring spot and I also
need a and another term that's talking
about repulsion that they really don't
want to be at the same spot so this is a
Bose Harbor model because it's talking
about bosons and the hubbard model is
yes and the recent result from this here
by a new Charles David Gossett and Zack
Webb is that this particular model on a
very complicated graph that you deciding
what graph you make and then ask you a
question about the ground state is QM a
complete while this is interesting that
what's happening here that you're not
changing the different of the couplings
at different places the interaction is
the same for all particles except you
choose the graph like how can they can
hop so that's another way that you can
get instances out of a problem so same
tape type of interaction but just a
different interaction graph meaning that
like the particle can hope you decide
like who's connected to who but the way
of connect or correctly is the same yes
general graph so again very non-local in
the geometrical sense that's not not
that great that's not not that great
yes so really what what are we going to
talk about in the local Hamiltonian case
that what's really interesting there
that the local to local Hamiltonian on a
2d lattice is QM a complete so it really
is that things are interacting only with
the nearest neighbors of course that has
its shortcomings the shortcomings that
like we some of the cappings has to be
have to be really really strong and
really strong meaning like polynomially
stronger than others where the
polynomial is pretty high and the
polynomial is the size of the so again
it's not realistic yet it's so you're
basically just doing
sometimes I wonder is this a mystery
okay and is it really a tower listen
than a general a general graphic assault
is the embed ability even something that
saw it it's an almost trivial result
okay I see we can talk about it okay
okay so I I didn't know I didn't realize
that so that's a good point you know I
think that long-range erection is not a
Korean physics is you know maybe that's
a little too pessimistic one example is
that people have done is trapped a bunch
of dipoles in an optical lattice and
then these things interact with sort of
a power their interactions fall off like
a power of the distance which is you
know pretty much which is effectively
long-range and even though the optical
lattice is regular they might be filled
randomly with maybe there's a dipole
here and there's not a dipole and a
different one so you have kind of a
different random filling of it each time
and then you could ask can you solve
what the effect of these interactions
for any particular filling that comes
kind of close to this problem but your
guess for anything it's not why these
interactions right there's some immune
field well then the graph is yeah it's
not a totally arbitrary ground yeah that
sort of thing yeah no that's not cool in
flat no but if you this gets closer you
could ask could I have an algorithm that
works wherever they land and then you
know
this is the reason simulating pastries
do you really want to seem like a so
let's so if we talk if you call cool
oblong rage then then maybe we do you
have him so let's hour off falling off
what we have exponentially falling off
our correlations in particular systems
in ground states what we want to talk
about a little bit later so really when
you have these models they're pretty
rich when you just look for example for
the hubbard model just it's not though
it's the fermionic model you can spend a
lifetime with it there are like millions
of results and people are modeling
magnetism with this another manner
models are models of an ice type for
example when you have four bonds between
the molecules where you have on one bone
the electron can be either on this side
or on that side closer and then all you
really need there so you can draw arrows
and see how they move move around or
another another thing would be a dimer
model where you're looking at systems
where or neighboring electrons tend to
like a couple into into singlets into
like a spin spin zero state and then
these things can like flip around and
move and so there are there are many
many models and you can really look at
it for example on a triangular lattice
or the hexagonal lattice on the cargo
Meletus and different ones and people
are doing this a lot so let's ask what
are the questions that we're asking
about these metals so first the question
that are kind of static so one of the
typical question is optimization
what's the ground state so what's the
ground state of a stingless what's the
lowest energy or really what's the best
way to fault a protein and again all
these things are governed by local
Hamiltonians where you've got like only
you can decouple everything into
interactions of the small things that
are nearby
these problems are hard because of
frustration so very often when you have
intimate family interaction you always
find something that just you cannot
satisfy everything so then the state is
not really a local ground state or so
still where everything would be happy
like you could just make this help you
make this happy and just do do
everything like this and you have a sim
simple algorithm but really finding the
girls that can be hard describing the
cows they might be hard as well so
frustration is an interesting sign all
that is there so we're talking about
ground states the ground state is a
state that is that's cool so iron
systems like always in the ground state
well we find systems in nature that
don't want to go to their Gaza there are
like hard to hold it like are like stuck
somewhere can we use like oh I don't
know these bubble models to solve toilet
reason like to do computation the
problem is that you will get stuck in a
minima even just though the algorithm
the simulated annealing algorithm when
you have a system and then you try to
flip spins and if the energy goes down
then you take it and then it sometimes
you think of like thermal fluctuations
and you can flip something up and then
can't continue and maybe lower the
energy down this is really coming from
something when you have a material and
you try to make actually you make a
magnet so when you cool you first heat a
material up and then you let it cool
down and it will it will freeze in
different domains where the
magnetization is kind of like pointing
in the same way but really if you have
domains that are not pointing in the
same way then the magnet is weaker then
it could be so then you anneal you try
to like heat up like some part of it and
then let it cool down so that it locks
to the near to the nearest domains as
well this is how things are done in
practice or or really like you're trying
to make a better feel that's like better
organized as a better structural
properties than you can do this and
there are and and that's technology but
it's it's very clever technology okay
which one that one those are when you
have a pins and you're trying to find
Steiner trees so like as a tree like or
lines that are connecting these pins and
the overall length is the shortest
possible and this is a difficult problem
but bubbles possibly solve it because
bubbles are trying to find like the
smallest smallest surface area so when
you put a soft feel on these pills on
these pins in my like little jump around
and then like end up in something that's
good but really here it's good
here it is in this optimum solution but
very often you end up in something like
this and there are problems with
precision like how thick do you make
these pins how far do you make them can
you can you really scale this
computation up or not so it's cool as a
model but it doesn't really work in
practice and there have been quite a few
other proposals and like crackpots
really are trying to push this alright
and we gonna talk make a connection
between optimization and conference
constraint satisfaction problems and the
spin glasses so really how classify how
hard it is to find constants another
question that we asked about that it's
kind of static about these many body
systems is not only the ground States
but what are the excitations the
excitations are is important what or
what all I heard yesterday was asking
that like really what happens at higher
temperature that excite thermal
excitations really matter and will the
system get interesting there or not and
or what's the whole spectrum
second thing is like can we solve the
system or can we at least integrable
means that like we can please do
something like pick up of the whole
complicated interactions into like
smaller parts that we possibly might
solve or not and what's really
interesting there that we look for
symmetries in the system we try to like
to find some clever transformation that
makes it okay we all will solve it or we
at least we're trying to get some
answers on like what what the states
should be like and then get some
approximations out of that or we're
looking at bulk properties which means
that is the system really magnetic or
not is what happens when I heat it up
will it like stuff suddenly start being
disordered or not will it really like
melt like ice or something so are there
any phase transitions in the system the
dynamical questions are questions about
or simulating the system yes
yeah so like really so first when at
this temperature I would have you like I
would look at the audience and like
everybody's sitting randomly and then
like when when we really like cool the
place down like will will it will
everybody Hubble in just one corner and
the nature of the auditorium will be
different then like qualitatively is
that equivalent to asking about the
nature of studying properties the
properties of eigenstates and different
parameter regimes let's say really like
that
for example the ground as the ground
state at high temperature is disordered
so really like our spins don't care
about each other and the ground state at
low temperature is ordered and these
things are different
okay so let's see what I actually said
okay let's an I say what the state of
the system that this temperature will be
okay thanks
so let's go to dynamics or we want to
sell simulate the feathering equation
see how the systems will evolve these
things can be pretty complicated
for example scattering really you'd like
what this is what physicists have been
doing for a long time like you have some
material and then you shoot something I
need to see what comes out and try to
figure out what what has happened inside
the material like even find find its
properties or really be able to simulate
what's what's happening in and this
thing is difficult because well there's
a recent result from last year that
really like simulating scattering in the
balls Hubbard model so you have you have
a graph and then you would imagine that
you have a few particles coming in and
seeing where they come out these Q is
can make a computer it's it's a bqp
complete so if you are able to solve
scattering problems you would have a
quantum computer or there are these
recent results on boson exampling that
like again you have a river system or
just the beam splitters whatever and
then you should send some photons in and
depending on the statistics of how they
come out might be solving difficult
problems so when what is hard about
simulating dynamics the hardness is at
the states that we've got are becoming
more and more entangled as we evolve
that means when we make a cut in the
system say Schmidt decomposition it
might the cut becomes more and more
costly so it's harder and harder to
describe the states the second thing
that we do and I'll try to simulate in
dynamics is something called quenching
quenching is that like we have a system
that's really in its ground state and
then we suddenly change the Hamiltonian
and then see what happens like how
things thermalized
like or if it's we will it like
thermalize very easily or we will get
some oscillations or we get will we get
something that just strange and
typically we look at the B
of correlations in the system once we
change something and see how they move
how signals propagate in the system and
a very useful tool that you will hear a
lot is the leap robinson bound that's
talking about when you have a system and
the interactions are local really in the
system so when you change something here
the expectation value of operators like
say I measure though that's been here as
it came here will not be related until
time passes that's related to some
velocity of a signal spreading and this
velocity is related to the strength of
the interaction that's the leap Robinson
bound so for example I know if my
friends are doing simulations like
Valentin my colleague in you know in
Vienna they take a system and then they
change something here and then see how
the how the signal is spreading and they
don't really look at the whole system
but they look only at a window that has
something to do with the with the
velocity that they predict and really
okay they choose the window wisely so
really the signal goes like that and
they they look at how the correlations
are changing in systems finally when we
have the dynamics that sort of what I
would want to talk about more on
Saturday is we want to utilize the
dynamics so one thing would be control
or preparing particular States second
would be state transport when you have a
chain and then I prepare something here
and I would like it to appear on the
other side or we might think of it like
well what's really happening in these
photosynthetic complexes like it's
photons coming into a little bit of
floral floral field not chloroform how
how are they collected an ethereal one
spot where they really we need them
another thing is that I'll probably be
more on Saturday especially what John
Prisco is going to talk about this
simulation that we have some quantum
mechanical system and we want to
simulate another quantum mechanical
system with it possibly in a range of
parameters that's not accessible here
we're just making when things are much
simpler and finally we want to utilize
the dynamics for algorithms just like
here it's a quantum walk can we use the
quantum walks which is just spreading of
excitations in a many-body system maybe
1 excitation maybe
any excitations that's something that's
people are trying to investigate
nowadays for example like this
algorithmic success in the quantum
computing that's traversing a tree with
a mess inside in the middle if I and
your child so let's go a little bit more
into the question that we are asking so
the three types of questions the
eigenstates
symmetries and the parameters so first
when we talk about spectrum one thing is
that all when we have a lattice and we
have electrons moving around some of the
electrons are bound to their nuclei and
some of the icons might be free will
what will their energies be so there's a
whole whole area of a band theory where
you're looking at different momenta so
like how the electrons could possibly
move what their energies would be and
there are spaces that for example they
are not some energies are not available
and then when you have different levels
in a system and you've got it a certain
number of electrons so some electrons
will be here in this bottle in these
states that are really tied some will be
in a valence bond which is like the last
one like all fibers away from the
nucleus and possibly there might be some
that are left over and I just really
unbound and would be able to move around
the system and you would have a
conductor you would have a metal but
there could be other like allowed
energies that for example at a
reasonable temperature the electrons
would be probably just running around
and with fluctuations maybe they could
jump to a band that that conducts that
they or they could move around or maybe
somewhere in between
you got a metal you got a semiconductor
or when really the electrons are here
and the next band the next allowed
energies are much higher let's say the
thermal fluctuations there in the system
then we will get an insulator now the
question would be a question about the
gap in the system so a thermodynamic
limit is when you make a system larger
and larger will that assist States that
are getting closer and closer to the
ground state or is the ground say just
unique and sitting there this question
so very often in the constructions that
we were doing you know
computer science is that we're talking
about in inverse polynomial gaps with
you know these results we really or
about Jamaica more completeness very we
have inverse polynomial games so
condensed matter physicist those are
just gaps that are closing so that all
the systems for them are gave us when we
have a gap then we've got to hear about
this more flow from zeph you know one
day we get an area law and we know this
inspires numerix that really when you
have a region then the entropy when you
look at the reduced density matrix of
the system will kind of depend just on
the size of the boundary which in case
here in a 1d would be just a constant
there is entropy so when you look at the
reduced density matrix not because of
thermal fluctuations so because there's
some temperature but in a quantum system
it's because of quantum correlations so
that the system cannot be written as as
a product and statistics like so many
different choices but it really is a
superposition and when you look at the
reduced density matrix you get some
entropy from that correlations for when
an area law is in the order we expect
them to fall exponentially with distance
and then again inspires the numerix that
we're going to talk about moral insanity
of course also when you have a gap in
the system you might think if you can
simulate or some of the dynamics you
might just use imaginary time evolution
that's a typical method where you
instead of simulating the shreditor time
evolution you use imaginary time so
really you're multiplying a state with e
to the minus H some other tau and that
really like if you can implement that
with some approximation then you're
finding ground States and this is like
just in Markov chains like you've got
things that are getting closer and
closer to the stationary state here of
depending on what the gap is in the in
the graph here you've got something
that's there will be going down and down
closer to the ground state depending on
the gap so general a general idea is
that when you have get systems finding
the ground state should kind of
easy right but of course like this part
might be that might be difficult so it's
not not that easy and the clever way of
doing it you're here in that stop and if
there are no states nearby so we have a
gapless system oh we can ask questions
so really what are the states that are
nearby sorry
are they states that are like simpler
than the ground states and this is
connection to the PCP theorem and you'll
probably hear about the trivial state
and conjecture or from from Thomas later
and deciding whether system is gapped or
gapless when you make the system large
this was the question for example in the
Heisenberg model for a particular model
but in general this is uncomputable and
that's been proven this year by toby
cubed David Peres Garcia and Michael
uncomputable weather system is gapped or
gapless when you make it large yeah so
this is one D nearest neighbor
interactions horribly hugely dimensional
particles at the moment no no no it's
not one needs 2d it's 2d sorry we would
like to do it in 2d in 1d but we don't
know how to do it yet oh yes so actually
the interaction is the same everywhere
oh I see but the interaction itself has
a polynomial number of like or bits so
that's the decide I'll tell you what the
problem is you encode a larger input by
making the rational entries of the
Hamiltonian yes the entries of the
Hamiltonian are the things that encode
the instance
also as a function of precision
he's making he's making the interactions
more complex
yep
if you know you but it's just one
interaction same interaction every
weapon you can see in every of it but
you can make that particular interaction
more complex and as a function of that
interaction
maybe this is this might be some hint of
why really computing like what the
system is get or get less might be so
difficult but maybe not because really
like saying the Heisenberg model is just
one particular model so just like when
we were looking at the easing model in
3d we don't know we cannot really figure
everything out about the system but
really it's just one instance so maybe
some somebody will go and solve it but
maybe solvable models are just some way
accidents so one more thing about gaps
that are relates to the quantum PCP
theorem possibly in the local
Hamiltonian problem we're looking at the
ground state of a system we have in the
yes cases where the ground state energy
is lower than something that we're
looking at there's an eigenvalue gap in
the in the Hamiltonian itself that's all
and there's an eigenvalue gap in the
Hamiltonian itself when there are no
solutions or for some difficult problem
or really when the ground state energy
of a local Hamiltonian is higher and
we're trying to decide between these
cases and there's a promise gap in
between currently the results go like 1
over polynomial we would actually want
them to go like em but in practice it's
the eigenvalue gaps of the Hamiltonians
are now much bigger than the promised
gap and we would like to get something
where possibly the promised gap would be
large or maybe get these Hamiltonians
that are involved in here to have like
large large gaps
well so this I'm just I'm just saying
that we know in the KMA completeness
results that we've got the eigenvalue
gaps of the Hamiltonians themselves are
larger than the promise get much justo
any any of the like camp Akita ever I
gave to Yoko Hamiltonian see the
polynomial small Bach but right there so
they run over Polly squared and these
are okay so it's also involved you know
in here is like the size of the system
plus the plus the promise of the
original problem okay you're right there
so let's talk about it a little bit more
later but but you're right that if the
original problem there could be other
things that are really nearby other
social that are nearby then then these
gaps will be small too but what I'm
saying that even if these caps are small
these gets even smaller so and we would
like to get something that has a large
promise gap and I'm trying to see like
whether they're whether they're what the
relationship of these is and if we can
make them both bigger possibly
go back to that slide a I'm a little
confused just about the big picture of
this when you say we would like we would
like you so we're trying to possibly get
a theorem that would say that like you
have a Hamiltonian that has some
interactions and you're asking for what
the ground state energy is is it lower
than this or it's higher than this with
some precision parameter and where the
stronger theorem would have a stronger
precision parameter but right now the
precision parameter is really just like
one over polynomial and the polynomial
is pretty large and the reason why it's
pretty large it comes from the
eigenvalue gaps in the Hamiltonians that
are involved in the constructions are
also 1 over inverse polynomials and this
promise gap is even worse than that so
I'm trying to motivate like what we also
would like to do this semester is
possibly do something about about that
try to come up even with a different
construction yes yes that's what we
would like really like say my personal
question doing in a motor in complexity
is trying to find the simplest sounding
problem that would still be with like
really strong promise that would still
be ridiculously hard my time is also
slowly running out but I'll still still
go go with this a little bit more so
what does it mean to solve a system you
know in many body physics you've got
this book and those are the suitable the
models that are exactly solved and
they're not that many of them solving
really means like calculating say the
partition function the free energy of on
the system
or also forming sometimes could be a
little bit less the system that's
integrable so for example here when you
have this Heisenberg model in 1d you
realize that this system has a symmetry
and that conserves like overall total
spin in the Z direction so when you now
look okay there's a invariant subspace
with just one particle 1 excitation and
then you solve for what the eigenvectors
would be and there will be waves and
then you start solving some what would
happen for like two particles and that
just gets difficult
but we have an really ingenious better
answers that tells you like what are
going to be what's the relationship
between the different coefficients for
like if the excitations are at different
places and then we turn diagonalizing
the whole Hamiltonian in the subspace of
two three four five excitations you
change it into algebraic equations for
these coefficients that are in some way
easier but and different from what you
had before and you can solve it for
these small numbers but as the numbers
go higher and higher it gets more and
more difficult so we still still say
that the model is kind of like solvable
but it's not really something that this
goes without effort so it may may be
really difficult but still there might
be some insight into the system where
you use a symmetry to simplify a problem
but it still can be difficult afterwards
okay oh let me not talk about this so
really one way when we're looking at
things in practice we have a try to do
some solo to solve something with
insight to the approximations and then
we check it because there are very few
models that really we have a formula so
now we check it for example with our
exact diagonalization so this is a
business slide from from and resolutely
from Innsbruck so what when we used to
do numeric when I was a grad student I
could go like I just normally thirteen
spins or possibly like twenty spins the
number space is growing like crazy but
when you take into account different sub
spaces and symmetries in the system you
can really go higher you parallelized
it's on on many graphical cards and so
so in practice for spin models this is
the challenge trying to solve these spin
models in 2d and you can go to like 40
spins on a square lattice it's not
really a big square but what's involved
in here are like many many many basis
states and you're optimizing in that and
really we're not getting the whole
spectrum we're just looking at low-lying
States but still we're way far from
where we have been so we were checking
our numerix these store whatever you get
from Montecarlo whatever get from like
tensor product stays compact or
something against this exact
diagonalization or what I was saying
yesterday against a particular model
where we know what the solution is then
in fractional quantum Hall effect again
like you go to like many many billions
of states these are there you have again
like a lattice and electrons that are
coming in and then you try to fill in
more and more lifers and see how they're
behaving or when you're doing quantum
chemistry then you can change that to
Humbert models and we're going to talk
about probably again maybe I'll set it
when there's small time
oh no why this is difficult you can go
to 20 sites not not that man so any
method that goes higher is great
understanding a system the method that
we got is exact eigen ization Montecarlo
try to just look at like small clusters
and then like generalize into some
something bigger out of that or our arm
is going to talk about more about mean
field when you think about the
interaction of a particle with its
neighbors instead of just taking the
particle interactions individual you
take it with an average of our neighbors
and you think that the average is the
same everywhere
so that simplifies a lot or you do an
expansion a series where you take
there's some parameter in the system of
like which interaction is stronger or
weaker so start with when real
interaction is really strong and you do
an expansion in s perturbation Theory of
saying like what what happens if you
take like the first order second order
third order of the other interaction or
you look at the system at different
scales and you try to find the relevant
length scale with the renormalization
group methods or for example people are
using REM the replica trick when you're
trying to calculate the partition
function with the help of a formula
where now instead of just having one
system you take like many copies of the
system and things might get simpler
there but this is a physicists trick and
say I mean code all honesty is making
this rigorous then we've got phase
transitions when we vary parameters and
the nature of the states is changing so
for example a classical phase transition
in easy magnet that you vary temperature
and as you where very temperature the
magnetization
instead of going to well when you coul
assist them down when on only when you
make a and a particular temperature when
you you put a magnet in a field and then
you turn off that field the magnet
doesn't really go into like zero
magnetization but it stays frozen
somewhere so it like at a different
field at all at a particular temperature
you might get different results
okay I'm not sorry let me let me say
that again when I'm varying temperature
and I'm looking at the magnetization it
might be that here I get a discontinuity
that like for different different metals
of field like something will jump like
really to different different places or
if I oh I have a system that's ordered
and then I increase the temperature
suddenly might become disordered or may
be conducting or insulating then what
happens that the magnetization is I look
at in terms of temperature or as I get
away from a particular critical
temperature when things are ordered or
disordered this is the magnetization
this is the temperature you might get a
different scaling behavior that this is
the scaling of with a particular
critical exponent some power it turns
out that systems become fall into
different universality classes of like
what these exponents are like how things
are changing when you get away from the
critical point and then there was
something that's much more complicated
is when you go into quantum phase
transitions when you don't have
different temperatures that you do
everything at a zero temperature and
then you change a parameter like for
example you have like again one type of
interaction that's the ferromagnetic
interaction in an easy model and then
you've got a field that gets like or
stronger or weaker and you'll just look
at the ratio of these and suddenly there
might be a case that like there's a the
gap gets small bit from the ground state
to the first excited state or really as
it gets small
instead of getting something
looks like girl in the spectrum
something that looks like this you might
get something that looks like almost
like that so there's a discontinuity in
the ground state energy and if there's a
discontinuity something where'd this
happen
the nature of this the ground state is
changing a lot and this could happen at
a particular parameter and then we what
we're investigating is what's happening
when we increase the temperature will
this behavior
stay there or will the thermal
fluctuations change it what's happening
then and this is a follow whole another
area that I really want go into I'll
skip this part there are phase
transitions in control in computer
science that you know about in this hour
the set onset transition let me try to
complete because my time is running out
basically computing the energy of a
ground state can be very difficult and
we can show that it's np-complete for
particular models say like for the one
that's here or for the easing model in
2d with varying strengths and with an
extra magnetic field we can show that
another problem is difficult that really
even when finding the ground state is
easy but figuring out what's happening
with the statistics of the system when
you try to calculate the partition
function really at zero at low
temperature the Sun like this is
dominated by only ground states but
what's the lowest lowest terms here so
it it is related to counting degeneracy
of degeneracies in the system how many
ground states do we have and it can turn
out that these problems can be sharp P
complete for non plus a for the easing
model for non planar graphs or for pot
smokers then in the quantum case things
get more difficult and different because
they're all
let's just know let me just give you a
couple problems that we know that are
that are difficult quantumly and just
ask that we would want other ones that
could possibly help us with a lot of
high note on this one problem that we
have that it's qm a complete is a
problem where you take it you have a
circuit and you can ask can i feed
something to this circuit that what
comes out is a state etcetera another
problem is that I have a circuit does
this circuit ever do anything like is
this circuit non-identity another
question is I have a system I have all I
give you reduced density matrices so
like pretend that there's a state and I
will tell you like how the state looks
like when you look at a few particles at
a time only and now I ask is this thing
consistent can I make a whole global
state out of these little parts
another question like that is that are
computing the density functional
Universal density functional you know
you know quantum chemistry or another
question like that that's difficult is
just asking I have an super operator is
this taking a system and is it
completely mixing it or is there
something that's that stays these are
these are the different types of
problems that we have that are that we
know there are QM a complete besides the
one that's the most important that was
the most important one that's
translating the verification for a
particular problem so we have a quantum
circuit and you're asking can I feed
this circuit a particular state that the
circuit will accept and this can be
mapped into the local Hamiltonian
problem and that's the main the biggest
that's the problem that we're going to
be discussing a lot here asking about
the global minimum of an intro of a
system where the interactions are say on
a 2d grid and they're qubits or asking
about on one degree than the particles
are saying ad dimensional this can be
this is very different but I'm not
trying to ask other other problems other
problems that could help us with you
know content matter to try to classify
something that would not be directly
changing or like verification of a
computation directly encoding that but
something that's more clever just like
for example in the showing the NP
completeness of the easing model they're
really where an encoding computation but
they were changed to changing it into
calculating maximum cuts so we have
different problem we're just showing
that that program is difficult to some
very interesting insight we would like
to get something like that in the in the
quantum case and we don't have much of
that yet there are things like that
we're getting possibly like getting
problems that are more like of a graph
nature so this is you know in the recent
results of Andrew Charles and David
Cosette and they have they're asking
questions about particular graphs where
you can calculate the connections
efficiently and you ask for the minimum
eigen value in this graph can we use
some things like that to possibly help
us with showing things like the quantum
PCP theorem possibly all right we're
going to talk about the different
variance and complexity on a Saturday
and so I'm gonna conclude here we talked
about different models in condensed
matter and we try to I'll try to explain
what are the questions what are the
classic questions what are the quantum
questions that we're asking they're
trying to find a common language there
for example what are the ground states
like this can be turned into the analog
of the colliding theorem into hardness
of the local Hamiltonian problem the
second thing that I want to focus on
more on Saturday is what are these
things good for
can you can control systems transport
excitations do something in chemistry
understand or like even just talk about
reactions and possibly make it make a
computer and there are different ways
that we can look at things whether
what's the local dimension was the
interaction geometry are the things
time-dependent or not are the things
translation invariant father what what
about the gaps and the promises and the
correlations in the system how they're
changing and how strong are the
interactions themselves even relative to
one another and on Saturday I'm going to
continue more with the tools that we're
using to solve these type of systems
focusing
yeah sure like the dynamical questions
are really like we or we can use them to
make a computer that's that's the kind
of type of thing that I that I am
thinking of I don't know those those
programs are generally are about ground
states so so really not like drill this
evolved into I don't I don't know about
the questions of that type there will be
Q a complete they'll be interesting to
think about it but then this non expert
one may I see all these other
descriptions right like the quantum
circuits or our innocence was on
something so when a physicist looks at
that is that this here is an
approximation to this reality despite
the Hamiltonians so what how do I see
the circuit say the circuit model and
with the Hamiltonian circuit circuit our
implementable by real life systems
so just circuits is just as a call a
construct that needs something physical
yeah I'm under it yeah so really when I
see a unitary you in practice it means
like okay I have to have a system and
there for example implementing a unitary
might be that you have several
excitations like these bosons running in
in their child's model on in a graph
where they're interacting the respect
are like in the both Hubbard model and
when they come out what has happened
with them is that I can draw it as a
gate
so under sir so circuits are useful but
in practice they have to be implemented
so like I really need to shine a laser
on some on some ions in some trap yes
but now is that two phases is that
translation look exact or is there
something lost or some things that are
drop it's an approximation so
definitely they're approximations really
in and in in practice we cannot really
do these things exactly we would say
would love to but that's it's difficult
yes but we can do it also with
time-invariant Hamiltonians just oh
those are the type of quantum walk
models that I've been looking at where
you have particular interactions set up
and then you let something run the
Hamiltonian stays the same or stays or
unchanging it depends on what you put in
is an initial system and see what comes
out of that system so it doesn't really
have to be that the particles are
heating them like this as well again
looking at particular noise in the
Hamiltonian model might be different
than looking at early that can be there
can be trouble if you if you cannot
really implement these things precisely
or even like in the models that we're
looking at or weather with a particle
fixed Hamiltonian if there's disorder in
the Hamiltonian so that the couplings
are not really the same everywhere but
they can change them instead of like
having particles running around you
might get something like and there's
some water addition that they would be
stuck so there are problems and we would
like to do something about to see the
stability of the result so for example
you have we have a result for particle
Hamiltonians what happens if we change
them slightly will will the results hold
on or not
and definitely their stair stuff that is
not lost in a direct translation but
with noise and practice it's probably
our best guess right and I think that
that raises two questions one is that
maybe maybe supposedly computing energy
maybe seems to me then it makes sense to
to focus on rotation so let's try to
answer that or comment on that a little
bit yeah it's exactly right so it's also
what we would like to do with or say
with the possible PCP theorem or
something like if you vary things a
little like is it even imagine that we
have like a thermal noise would coming
into a system will that will things
change a lot or will things not changing
what happens with you further we got
slightly oh so we are so now we have a
quantum Hamiltonian that's written down
and that's at zero temperature but in
real life you would have instead of just
this Hamiltonian you would have
interactions with other things that are
nearby and you can model the thermal
noise with with that possibly or
so it's it is good to focus on things
that are stable I will be very happy
let's say that with many many things
we're we're happy that we have them and
there will be stronger if we could get
the changes in practice like you need
polynomial precision in the in the
entries in the Hamiltonian and the
promise itself is like one over
polynomial and the size of the system so
you could think what what will happen if
you make the system larger we really
impractical be able to to measure and
just distinguish things and especially
for example in the models that I'm
looking at like in the cantos at that
Sun frustrated that really like other
model should be like everything should
click in space exactly and that that
thing won't survive
then a lunchable questions to looking at
subluxation proof and then asking polar
system so they so stable change so that
this one question one question to is so
in in cusco design so there's this
notion of complexity placed between me
in worst case and everything smoothly so
you Kristin second so it's a fix
analysis of Mister news complexity is
basic in a constants also provides some
parameters for particle system they are
not going to be precise so therefore it
makes sense on average so we're happy
how we looked at average complexity and
sense that not like average instances
but just like you take a particle
instance and ever each other was what's
around I think we we have not but we
have looked at say like random models of
quantum shot and that's all so when the
interactions are chosen randomly what
happens or like the projectors are
chosen randomly what happens then and it
really like this is more interesting to
the to the many body physicists because
it's all something that you don't have
control about it itself okay it's a
model where it's kind of pretty much
like truly random like you have a mango
you have a system and then like though
there are some small disturbances in the
system and it they're kind of like
average and then you see what what
happens there but we're getting more
towards in practice that we can control
systems more and more so it it actually
makes sense to talk
about things where where we really
control the interaction and we can even
possibly think about the worst case but
but analyzing the average one is
definitely interesting